they work before let's bring them back
Doctor Who this time this time I am
ranking the revived villains villains
that were originally introduced in the
classic Doctor Who that have since been
revived and made an appearance in new
Doctor Who
new doctor Houdini being what started
with Christopher Eccleston back in 2005
now I've got 11 entries on this listing
before anybody calls me out on it
Rassilon is not on this list because by
my estimation he was not villain in the
classic series he was referenced he kind
of appeared once as like this sort of
old figure and it looked like he was a
nice guy but he was not the direct
villain of that story that he appeared
in I don't think he counts if you want
to argue with me yeah have fun but he's
not on this list so number 11 the mock
crow I think you couldn't put these guys
any higher me it's big Krabs now it to
be fair it's actually really hard to
properly judge this because the mock
right error the original thing they
appeared it is one of the remaining Lost
episodes that they haven't been able to
find any record of the original tapes
got wiped so it's may seem unfair to
judge but I mean the big crabs that's
what they are they're big crabs and as
they appear in new Doctor Who they're
big crabs at the bottom home pit I mean
it's if they basically serve as a kind
of fun Easter egg but they could have
been anything
number 10 the Autons and the Nestene now
I feel like these guys really need a
writer who really loves this valise
villains and really wants to do
something inventive with them because I
feel like placeholders I feel like they
were brought in to be that first episode
of new Doctor Who because they were the
very first villains for the third doctor
and they were the first villains in
color and they're functional and they're
about as functional here as they were in
the classic series but like there's
nothing new done with them there's
nothing interesting done with them
they're just kind of yeah they're there
number 9 the Ice Warriors now I do kind
of like the episode cold war
a lot of people but it doesn't do a heck
of a lot with the Ice Warriors and
honestly it could have been almost
anything I do kind of like the redesign
for the X words but let's be honest that
original design for these characters is
so dated and looks so bad that remaining
true to it all they ended up with
something that looks kind sheezy kind of
goofy there really was no way around
that value for my part I'm kind of okay
with that but I can't really say that
it's good or that it's great and the
idea of taking the ice warrior out of
that armor is an interesting idea but I
wish they had not actually showed it I
like early on words like it's clear that
he's out and there's something else
going on here but I wish they hadn't
actually given us a full look that that
kind of brought it back down for me and
might even higher on the list if it
hadn't been for that number eight beside
lorian's this again these are villains
that I I think their new appearance is
about on par with their old one but it's
really kind of a rehash of what the side
laureen's gimmick always was and you
know what I would even lump in the sea
Devils with it because they were just
Sylar is underwater and the whole thing
is like this used to be their planet
they're upset that humans have taken
over nobody really wants a fight the
doctors trying to stop a fight but if I
just kind of happens anyway they really
just do that plot again only this time
it does not result in all Sylar is being
wiped out by unit because you know
that's a little uncomfortable so while
this bring in the bag is very true to
their earlier appearances it doesn't do
much different it doesn't really shake
things up at all so I mean it's it's a
decent copy-paste from old to new but
yeah just kind of his number seven the
Zygons these guys would have been
further up the list but I actually have
a lot of issues with the Zygon
two-parter that we got this past series
with Doctor Who now there are brilliant
moments in that episode especially
during the climax with the doctors
anti-war speech and the two buttons it's
amazing and brilliant I love it
but I'm not going to give credit to the
use of the Zygons specifically for that
that speech could have worked in any
other setting with other
villains the thing with the way the
Zygons breeze that when they first
showed up in the day of the doctor they
were cool they were functional they were
something that hadn't been seen for a
very long time they weren't even a
recurring villain the classic series
that only had one appearance so it was
cool to see in the back as he used but
then when they brought them back from
the two-parter they got really fast and
loose with exactly how their powers did
or didn't work and whenever they were in
Saigon form the all personality was gone
and they just stood there when yeah and
that kind of really old really quick and
I feel like they lost some of the
goodwill that the revival of these
creatures had gained from me initially
with day of the doctor and IgG it got a
little bit back with the second half of
that two-parter but yeah I think some
aspects of bringing these guys back was
just mishandle I'm sorry number six the
Sontarans now in terms of their initial
boom they're back great that is an
awesome two-parter the way it
reintroduces them as a species and it
just keeps really true to their military
militaristic nature and actually brings
them back to them being short because
classic series they seem to keep getting
taller as the series went on they got
really consistent about that but they
brought them back to them just being the
short little potato man but also having
the sense of honor and the right way to
fight I thought it was a brilliant way
to do it now I also really do like Strax
but the problem is if I'm being honest I
would have liked to put the Sontarans
higher but I can't because because I'm
Strax they've been played for laughs for
a while now and I finally strikes
himself being played for laughs but
unfortunate that's become so prevalent
that the species as a whole has not had
a proper return to villainy
really since that two-parter the closest
they came was when one of them showed up
in the Pandorica opens and that worked
pretty well but everything says that
they've been played for jokes have been
played for laughs and it diminishes
their value as bill
I'm not sure you could even use them as
villains again and have it work number
five the Cybermen this one's kind of up
and down for me it depends on the
episode I think the idea of having sort
of this alternate universe Cybermen as
opposed to actually bring back from
classic Cybermen not a bad idea it's
kind of interesting it's kind of fun the
look is great and the boot stomping is
awesome and so that initial two-parter
was good I should really like closing
time as an episode I like how that
brought back the cyber Matt's but then
there's stuff like nightmare and silver
that just it was an interesting visual
redesign but stories a jumbled mess and
it tried to make them scary again but I
think it actually overshot is like now
they're super fast and one of them you
have to book the whole planets like
could we a build back up to that instead
of trying to jump to it and then just
having the doctor defeat all of them
anyway so it does not really actually
make them scary again again didn't they
are excellent villains absolutely but
they haven't always been used
exceptionally well since they were
revived and brought back in the new
series number four the Daleks now I know
a lot of people probably expected these
guys to write at the top I mean they're
the top of my recurring villains list
why wouldn't they be the top here well
they may be it maybe if I were to redo
the recurring the villains list it might
be a different order anyway but my
justification for here is just that this
this revived Doctor Who did its job
which was to make these a viable villain
again because a look at the classic
Doctor Who if you weren't already
invested in Daleks goofy man they just
really are there were brilliant classic
Doctor Who stories don't get me wrong
but I mean you look at the thing you're
like that's the biggest baddie in the
universe really and they sold it they
made it work and they made these things
legitimately scary but since having done
that basically in the first series they
haven't done much to evolve the concept
past that they've tried a few times the
cult of Skaro was a good idea but then
you know that went downhill because we
had evolution of Daleks which was a
decent idea not well executed but then
since then it's just been Dalek hordes
back thought like hordes back and
they're kind of they've been running in
place for a little while now and that
basically kind of their trajectory back
in the original show as well they had a
brilliant introduction they got overused
a bit they got some interesting new
ideas but then they just kept showing up
showing up showing up and it just became
almost sort of obligatory and it was
starting to feel that way in the latter
half of classic whoo and it's starting
to feel that way a little bit now now
again I love Daleks they are in the
upper part of this list but I can't I
can't
edge them higher in terms of thinking
you know what was something from the
classic that they really did it that
they really did a phenomenal job
updating upgrading whatever so on that
note we head into our top three number
three Davros first of all the look looks
amazing Davros in the original series
Luc was inconsistent partly because they
were sometimes putting a mask for one
actor onto another actress face and it
looked just wrong
but Julian beech is able to embody that
rage and that mind and the manipulation
and all these things about him and I
think both of his appearances have just
been spot-on and they imaged oddly
humanize him and his second appearance
and yet still not lose that maniacally I
mean he has to be maniacal crazy a
danger to everything and this really
embodies that in it it's borderline
hammy but it just works and it's a
completely logical sort of continuing
the same thing and yet it doesn't feel
like as much of a repeat as the Daleks
do it I'm not entirely sure I can
articulate as to why I feel like Davros
is done a little bit maybe it's just
that he hasn't been as overexposed of
this Daleks have maybe because they show
more restraint how often they use him
but you know what I am I was happy to
see him back in person I was delighted
when he came back the second time and I
look forward to the next time they use
it
all right top two here we go number two
the great intelligence I think quite
possibly the best upgrade from what the
original use of the character was to
what was done with him in new Doctor Who
not immediate though he's used in the
Yuson the snowman was almost kind of
Easter egg II I mean if you knew who he
was back in the classic series it was
like oh okay that's kind of interesting
but then when they brought him back and
then he became so single-minded on
taking down the doctor and he didn't
even care about his own life anymore he
was willing to die just to enact the
most ultimate revenge he could think of
against the doctor oh that was good that
was a great progression for what had
been kind of a generic villain back in
the classic Doctor Who and in the
Snowman it was like okay interesting but
then when he came back oh this just he
went out on top as far as I'm concerned
and I don't think he'll ever come back
and I'm not sure they can wreak on him
out of the the depth that he had there
but man what a way to go out and I think
the fact that we're not going to get him
again might be the only reason that he's
not in the number one spot because the
number one spot I'm going to give
probably controversial e to the master
now I don't even love every appearance
the master has had when he initially
showed up Jung when Johnson was first
playing him actually really didn't like
him all that much it was too goofy it
was too corny was it was like a Saturday
morning cartoon version of the doctor
the bend when he came back in the end of
time and he was kind of crazy and he was
Lucien he was unstable I'm like that's
better I like that and I know not
everybody does but I loved Missy I think
missing is great I think she captures
and embodies the master really was a
character I loved how unpredictable she
is how dangerous she is but this sort of
makes my big point why I had to put the
master in this top spot because it's not
just that they brought back the Masters
that they are continuing to evolve the
master as the show goes on I think more
than any other of the villains that they
brought back from the classic era or
that they are using and continuing to
use in the news in the new era the
master continues to change and continues
to evolve because like the doctor he can
do that he has the ability to change and
shift regenerate come they can start
from scratch but I just loved the
progression while I've said that a
number of these characters have been
inconsistent I have
every appearance in the case of the
master and now Missy every time the
character shown up I've liked him now
her better so it's been a steady upwards
trajectory as opposed to a lot of these
elements that have been a bit more up
and down as it's gone along and for that
reason I've got to give him my number
one rebuy Doctor Who villain to the
master Missy
whatever she intends to call herself
next time she regenerates lover so
that's my list what are your thoughts on
villains from the classic era that have
come back in the newer [ __ ] you know
what alternately what's a villain who
hasn't come back yet
who you would like to I'm still holding
out that we're going to get omega it
boggles my mind that we haven't yet but
whatever it is for you drop something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it don't forget to Like subscribe
check me out on Twitter at council of
geeks follow the counsel of geeks
podcast on itunes and stitcher and until
next time this council is adjourned